[Applause]
[Music]
so i captured that before
they deleted it now if anyone doesn't
know that video
um and hopefully you get your appeal but
uh if not i'll i'll send you a copy and
uh so you can repost it because oh
definitely cause [ __ ] em
but uh [ __ ] em but here's the thing is
is
so i captured that video because i
thought may i might need a couple more
videos of him singing songs and i really
like that one
so i captured that one and i'm so glad
that i captured that one because it got
taken down so now it will live on
youtube
so for everyone and just boom boom
boom his daughter is crying
and he's like i can't go back to jail
baby so now this cop
is lying on the ground by the way eye
socket
shot she's fighting for her life because
this dude don't want to go back to jail
not they just say of course he got
arrested
but it's it's it's one of those things
that we need to discuss
in depth yes i know there are a lot of
deaf police out here
i know that for a fact but yeah whether
you want to hear it or not there are
cops out here who just do their jobs
they just do their jobs man they're not
trying to be those people but at the
same time
you you know you say to those people why
don't you turn those people in
that's an easy thing to say on the
outside to see if you're one of those
police officers in case you all have
never seen the movie serpico
uh honest cops do not farewell
they wear red hats you can see
[Music]
trump supporters
[Music]
the one trunk told you to do
don't worry that you're sitting in a
jail cell
i'm sure you've got a pardon for you
you dumb ass trump supporters
[Applause]
[Music]
he's trying to get these republicans on
record i mean politically what rand paul
is trying to do
is trying to get republicans on record
but i think
it actually could backfire on him
because a lot of these republicans could
say
oh well it's unconstitutional but uh
according to the evidence we still have
to convict him which is a cop-out
that it's unconstitutional it's just
this way of
of of condemning you know without
actually having to deal with what he
actually [ __ ] did which was
attempted insurrection against the
united states government
will cease to [ __ ] exist because
you've already got everybody up your ass
about the [ __ ]
okay about how you all are rolling now
and you think
that that i mean
do you live in this fantasy land where
there are no democratic voters
in your district where you think there's
nothing but republicans and you're going
to have
you know all the republicans are going
to come out and vote for you in 2022 and
2024
it's it's it's like you all think
that we're gonna forget about january 6
in two years in four years
bro that's not going anywhere that's not
going anywhere the republican party is
going to have to grab ahold of this
[ __ ] concept
you all better start walking on water
because that is the only way you all are
going to see any kind of solid
re-elections
anywhere down the line in the future